Scientists are hooking fish on opioids to
teach us how our brains get addicted to things.
It sounds crazy, but it’s actually just
science.
Over 100 Americans die from overdoses every
day.
Two million Americans have some kind of opioid-related
addiction, and overdoses are now the leading
cause of death for Americans under 50.
More people die in the U.S. of drug overdoses
than did from car crashes at their peak!
But an epidemic of opioids is so much more
difficult to fix than car crashes.
Car crashes peaked in 1972.
So, we created national speed limits, seat
belt requirements, drunk-driving laws…
Opioids are already controlled, and yet, we’re
still in trouble.
And that’s because we just… don’t understand
addiction very well.
So, to learn about our own brains, we’re
getting zebrafish addicted to drugs and it’s
teaching us a lot!
A new study hooked zebrafish on opioids using
behavioral training.
Basically, when they swam over a detector
they got hydrocodone.
After a while, they swam into shallower and
shallower water to get the same dose from
the detector; that’s risky drug-seeking
for a fish, a hallmark of addict behavior.
This is exciting, because now they can put
the fish into withdrawal and test drugs and
treatments on it.
I know that seems weird, fish are friends,
not humans.
But, we share 70 percent of our DNA with zebrafish,
and have engineered their brains to act more
like ours for studies.
Suffice it to say, they’re good analogs
for humans.
If we understand zebrafish addiction we can
hopefully translate treatment back to us.
And that mission is in progress.
One hooked zebrafish on morphine altering
over 254 genes.
Another optimistically found several receptors
and five opioid-related genes “so far.”
Studies into the four opioid receptors in
the zebrafish brain found one of them is star
of the show.
Then a follow-up study dug into how it works!
Basically, we’re making progress with the
drug-addicted-fish method.
There’s still tons to learn, but as we study
these tiny brains, we’re learning more about
our own!
And someday this could help us find safe treatments.
Hopefully, the zebrafish’s sacrifice won’t
be in vain but for now, we have to just keep
swimming.
While some scientists are using fish to learn
more about addiction, there’s a group of
researchers developing a vaccine that could
cure addiction all together.
We made a video about it, check it out here.
What do you think about all this?
Let us know down in the comments, like this
video, and don’t forget to subscribe so
you never miss an episode of Seeker.